hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to go over
all of the components in the structure
of the organelles mitochondria
so i have drawn
a mitochondrion here remember
mitochondrion ending in o-n is like a
singular
mitochondrion
mitochondria ending in an a means
multiple or plural mitochondria
so remember that mitochondria are
usually described as like the
powerhouses of the cell this is where
all of the not all this is where most of
the atp production happens most of the
energy production for a cell
now as we're going through this i want
you to keep in mind
that the there's a large range in the
number of mitochondria in a given cell
the average is around a hundred
mitochondria per cell so
each cell is going to have a bunch of
mitochondria in general um certainly
cells with greater energy needs are
going to have more mitochondria
now you might notice that i've tried to
color code this a little bit so in black
i have like the major membranes and um
sort of spaces
and then the smaller components that are
within
these membranes and spaces i have in
other colors that correspond to the
color in the diagram
so
now let's go ahead and get started we've
got our mitochondria in here it's kind
of this kidney bean shape we're going to
start with
basically letter a
this right here is our outer membrane
and you see all of these holes that i've
drawn are porons
and so what is the function of the outer
membrane it's really
there to separate
the functions that are happening inside
the mitochondrion
with the functions that are happening
outside of the mitochondrion out in the
cytosol
these porins
that are
uh creating these basically transport
channels in the outer membrane they
allow the transport of all kinds of
things into
the mitochondrion so this means that
adp
goes in remember that adp
is
required to make a tp so you have to get
adpn
and the atp
that is made also has to be able to
leave the mitochondrion so atp can cross
to exit the mitochondrion we also have
pyruvate
going in
i should pause here and say that i have
another video that is an introduction
to
aerobic respiration
so if things like pyruvate
and electron transport chain and atp
synthase and krebs cycle and all those
terms have you confused or nervous you
really need to pause this video and go
watch my video on aerobic respiration so
you understand the steps of aerobic
respiration and that'll help you better
understand this video so if you need to
go check that one out and then come back
but now let's move along pyruvate of
course is the major product of
glycolysis which is kind of that first
step in aerobic respiration the
glycolysis happens out in the cytosol a
pyruvate is created and pyruvate has to
be moved into the mitochondrion and it
enters the mitochondrion through all of
these porons
and so now let's go on to
sort of space v
this is the inter
membrane space remember inter
means between so this is the space
between the outer membrane that has the
porins and the inner membrane that has
all of these folds we'll talk about in a
second
so this inter-membrane space is a fairly
small
space
and it is there
to allow
hydrogen ion accumulation
so hydrogen ions accumulate
actually via the role of the electron
transport chain which we'll talk about
in a little bit
and they accumulate in this
intermembrane space
and that powers atp synthase which makes
all of that
that
atp that sort of energy currency of the
cell
so the intermembrane space can be kind
of broken down into two
other kind of smaller spaces there's the
peripheral space which is like the space
basically between
uh the inner membrane and the outer
membrane and then there's also the
inter-crystal space and that is the
space that's going to be like between
crease stay which we'll talk about in a
second
so
now let's move on to structure c and
that's the inner membrane now the outer
membrane had these porins
and this is actually pretty porous like
there's a lot of stuff that goes through
those porins
the inner membrane is a better kind of
gatekeeper or regulator for what's
actually kind of getting inside
now
it
this inner membrane
contains
multiple
electron transport chains i'm going to
abbreviate that etc
so multiple electron transport chains
those are the things that boxes in blue
and
atp
synthases
hopefully you recognize whenever
something ends in ace
ase that means it's an enzyme so atp
synthase
these are enzymes that synthesize hence
synthase synthesize atp and so all these
blue boxes are basically meant to
represent electron transport chains with
associated atp synthases
this is where oxidative phosphorylation
happens again if you if you need kind of
a refresher on what oxidative
phosphorylation is
please check out my video on aerobic
respiration
uh and then the inner membrane has these
these crease stay
and these are all these folds so if you
look at this
the black inner membrane
you know there's all of these folds in
here
and the purpose of the folds
is to increase
the surface area
to volume ratio now i also have a
separate video about surface area to
volume ratios and why having a high
surface area to volume ratio is
important for
cells and so check out that video if you
need a refresher on that
i will add that cells that have very
high energy needs are going to have more
crease day they're going to have more of
these folds packed into their
mitochondria that's to increase that
surface area to volume ratio
basically to create lots and lots of
extra space
to have
even more
of these extra of these electron
transport chains and atp synthases to
make even more atp so the cells with the
largest energy needs things like cardiac
muscle cells
they're going to have even more of these
crease stay these folds in the inner
membrane
now let's talk about compartment d this
is the innermost compartment so it's
like the fluid filled compartment inside
the inner membrane and this is called
the matrix the matrix
not the movie i know
the matrix the mitochondrial matrix has
enzymes for
the krebs cycle
so the krebs cycle has a few different
names it's called the krebs cycle the
citric acid cycle the tricarboxylic acid
cycle the tca cycle these are all
interchangeable names for the same
set of enzyme-catalyzed steps this cycle
where
remember that pyruvate that came into
the mitochondria
through the porins it gets oxidized and
converted into something called acetyl
coa acetyl coa feeds into the krebs
cycle and you get some atp production
and some other important things electron
carriers are generated
the electron carriers i should say they
accept high energy electrons that's what
i mean by created and that's all
happening in the matrix so the matrix
has those enzymes
for the krebs cycle
it also has an appropriate ph
for those enzymes remember this is
probably something i should have said
before
when you have all of these h plus ions
accumulating in this inter membrane
space
remember i'll write it uh over here
let's see
ph
equals the negative
log
of the hydrogen ion
concentration
so the more hydrogen ions you've got the
lower the ph that's where that negative
sign
helps you remember
so in this in this inter membrane space
you've got lots and lots of hydrogen
ions accumulating because of the work of
these electron transport chains and that
creates a very low ph out here
the matrix is going to have a higher ph
that's going to be more of an optimal ph
for these enzymes in the krebs cycle
so
at this point if you kind of want to
take a step back
and um
remind yourself where you where you're
at we have the outer membrane with the
porins we've got the inter membrane
space inside between the two membranes
then there's the inner membrane that's
where all the folds are that hold the
electron transport chains we've been
talking about and the matrix is on the
very inside compartment
and so now let's talk about
a few more of these smaller structures
that are inside the mitochondrion so
let's now go on to e
e
is the mitochondrial dna
remember
that
um if you're familiar with the
endosymbiotic theory
that teaches us about the evolution of
mitochondria and chloroplasts if you're
not and you want to be familiar i also
have a video about the endosymbiotic
theory so you can check that one out too
but that will explain to you why
mitochondria actually have their own
separate
mitochondrial dna
and sometimes you'll see this
abbreviated
as
lowercase m lowercase t
dna so that's the mitochondrial dna now
human mitochondrial dna has
37 genes
and here it's demonstrated in pink these
are circular chromosomes
similar to prokaryotic chromosomes again
check out that video on the
endosymbiotic theory if you need more
information about that
but there's 37 genes in our
mitochondrial dna and these
make
these genes control things like making
the proteins for the electron transport
chains
and making the
ribosomal proteins and the rrna for the
mitochondrial ribosomes
and um
you know not
all
of the proteins in here
are encoded for by the mitochondrial dna
some proteins in here do come from
nuclear dna but we've got those 37 genes
that contribute to a lot of the
functions that are happening inside the
mitochondria
i also want to add
that
human well really all mitochondrial dna
not just in humans but in all organisms
is inherited maternally what does this
mean our nuclear dna our chromosomes and
our nuclei
you've got two of each chromosome one
copy comes from your mother one copy
comes from your father that's nuclear
dna
mitochondrial dna is different
an individual's mitochondrial dna comes
strictly
from their mother
so a father never passes his
mitochondrial dna on only his nuclear
dna
a mother will pass on her nuclear dna
and her mitochondrial dna
now let's talk a little bit more about
these uh these ribosomes so in red here
this indicates the various ribosomes in
the mitochondria
these are
70s ribosomes sometimes they're called
mito
ribosomes
and these are specifically for
expressing mitochondrial dna 70s is a
measurement that distinguishes it from
the mitochon or sorry distinguishes it
from the ribosomes in our cytoplasm
which are 80s ribosomes 70s ribosomes
again check out that video on
endosymbiotic theory to learn why that
is important
but the 70s mito
ribosomes they are for expressing the
genes in the mitochondrial dna
i should also add that i said earlier
that every cell
is going to have multiple mitochondria
and the average is like 100 roughly 100
mitochondria per cell but there's a huge
range
now every mitochondrion
is going to have 1 to
of these mitochondrial dna chromosomes
so when you think about the average cell
having 100
mitochondria
and the average number of mitochondrial
dna chromosomes per mitochondrion is
about five for mitochondria that means
that on average again there's a huge
range but on average each cell is going
to have 500 roughly 500 copies of
mitochondrial dna
and so they need ribosomes to express
the genes in that dna now i just want to
very quickly remind you what the central
dogma of molecular biology is and that
is that dna
is
the molecule that holds our genetic
information
through the process of transcription
rna is synthesized using dna as a
template and then through the process of
translation
rna is used as a template
to make
proteins
so when i'm talking about expressing the
genes and mitochondrial dna this is what
i'm talking about
those genes have to get transcribed and
then
those rna transcripts go to the mito
ribosomes to be translated into proteins
so that's what we mean by
expressing the dna
now let's move on to our next structure
and that is going to be
g
right here
so these are the boxes in blue that i've
already indicated a few times these are
meant to be the electron transport
chains
abbreviated etc
and their associated atp synthases
if you need more information
on the electron transport chain and atp
synthase and how they function and what
they do please check out my video on
aerobic respiration that i mentioned
earlier
so the most important thing that i'm
going to kind of emphasize now is the
electron transport chains they create
the hydrogen ion gradient okay we've
already talked about that right here
they create the hydrogen ions they pump
hydrogen ions i'll try to draw it right
here they um they pump hydrogen ions
into
that where else can i draw it into
that inner membrane space so you get
a hydrogen ions
building up
in
you know accumulating
in the enter membrane space that's where
it drops the ph we already talked about
that
the reason this is important is because
this powers the atp synthases so every
single one of these electron transport
chains is going to have an atp synthase
nearby
that
uses the hydrogen ion concentration that
has accumulated
in the intermembrane space
to power atp synthase remember atp
synthase that is the enzyme that makes
atp that takes a dp and adds a phosphate
ion to it to make atp
and that is like the major
energy currency of the cell that's how
it's able to power a lot of its work
so now let's go on to h
that is cytochrome c
and i've drawn it as little kind of
green boxes in here now the cytochrome c
is loosely associated with the inner
membrane
excuse me
and it plays a few different roles it
actually plays a role in the electron
transport chain it can also regulate
cell apoptosis
and also importantly it processes or you
can also think of this as a
detoxification
of
reactive
oxygen
species
this is often abbreviated r o
s
so let me make this a little bit longer
so what does that mean
um
if you've watched my video on aerobic
respiration or if you know about aerobic
respiration
you know that each one of these electron
transport chains it has to have oxygen
at the end of it to be the final
electron acceptor without oxygen
the atp synthesis just grinds to a halt
and so
when you have all of this oxygen in here
acting as the final electron acceptor
allowing
the hydrogen ion gradient to be made
so that atp synthesis can proceed
you can have
various um kind of reactive oxygen
species for you think of if you have
free radicals uh super oxide um kind of
peroxide type things
um oxygen free radicals basically
these are very damaging
they can damage the structure of the
mitochondria and so you need a way to
detoxify them and cytochrome c helps to
detoxify these things now cytochrome c
is not perfect um over time as we age
mitochondria do become damaged
and they do have a decrease in function
because
of these reactive oxygen species and
that is just sort of part of normal
aging
okay
so now let's go to the final structure
and that is the granules in the matrix
these are storage granules so they store
a few different important ions one is
calcium ions
so calcium
regulates atp production a lot of the
enzymes
that are inside the mitochondria
contributing to the production of atp
they are sensitive to calcium and so
calcium helps to
regulate
all of those metabolic activities that
are helping to generate atp calcium also
plays a role in regulating cell death
when that's
necessary another ion that is stored in
these granules is
phosphate ions
um
let's see so where the calcium is ca
plus 2 phosphate ions are po4
negative three
um
let me think about this for a second
okay so phosphate ions these are
required to make atp so i've said this
before in this video adp that's
adenosine diphosphate it's got two
phosphate groups it needs another
inorganic phosphate that's one of these
um to
[Music]
to make atp which is adenosine
triphosphate and of course
this is sort of the major
function of the mitochondria the reason
that we have all of this stuff going on
all of these structures is to be able
to make
a lot of atp for the cell
through this oxidative phosphorylation
process
so
now that we've said all that please
remember to subscribe i have lots of
videos that can help you study so hit
the subscribe button hit that bell to
get notifications for new videos make
sure you check out some of my other
videos that i've mentioned like aerobic
respiration uh surface area to volume
ratio
and some of the other ones that we
talked about today
and other than that that's all i've got
so i just want to say thank you for
watching biology professor and i will
see you next time bye